here's brennan's son that he won't admit
about
my amish son this one's a little long
but yo what's up king of the sting gang
new listener here why is this [ __ ] sure
enjoying the content
just got done with some brazilian jiu
jitsu ain't nothing better than the
feeling of a full-grown man on top of
you choking you out brendan theo i'm
sure you know what i'm talking about
boys
um chen lay low bro i know you didn't do
anything to that glee lady i know it
wasn't you
dude don't worry about it um cat keep
your [ __ ] socks and shoes on around
those animals because those guys see toe
knuckle hair
and they just start acting on instinct
breathing all heavy and [ __ ] who
knows what they're going to do
uh lacey the barbecue bro i want to try
that [ __ ] i'm out here in denver i can't
find any good places
uh for good barbecue that's like subpar
or whatever
so let me know if you've got any
recommendations uh so i just watched the
episode
about um the asian food challenge [ __ ]
was hilarious
um so my debate topic today is most
attractive asian person
my vote is for korean i don't know why
like i just think their facial structure
like they were bred to be models i don't
know dude
i mean they're coming from a subpar
average looking dude like i just see
koreans and i'm like whoa what the [ __ ]
like why they look like they were
sculpted at a marble
but uh
i thought he was going to give us a
specific example of the hottest asian
yeah yeah but he went
type of asian what do you say cat
because being asian is it harder
to embrace the visuality you know what
comes into your eyes of
of other asians i do think that being
asian i can differentiate different
asians better
than like brennan kind of
picks up on the different asians but
aaron yeah he's
you're definitely getting better but
first i just refer to everybody as
asian yeah yeah that's good though
uh i think for me i think filipino girls
are the hottest girls and then
for guys i want to say
yeah i'm going to go filipinos if you're
into short guys if you're into taller
guys koreans ooh
yeah so koreans let's just say koreans
to make it korean
koreans all the way around yeah i don't
like shortcuts yeah filipino men
uh a lot of them
work at like uh senior care centers as
well senior carers they're nurses loving
they work in the post office oh really
yeah a lot of
uh filipino post office workers wow i
didn't know he talked about it
he does i love that i didn't know that i
feel much better mailing something
yeah i really do knowing that some
filipinos are going to handle it
because those people are usually really
nice people
i assume he only exclusively exclusively
dates asians
he gives me that vibe or at least he
tries to yeah he definitely hunts him
online yeah
who this is jokoy yes
[Laughter]
manny over here still working for the
post office
i just want to let you know that i saw
your netflix special
my god spectacular i mean what a show
if that uh comedian stuff doesn't work
for you
your uncle manny has a job over here
[Laughter]
you know there's one thing that's
bothering me huh i still haven't
received my uh
t-shirt
[Laughter]
we're raining around show all my friends
huh you owe me one of those
maybe you forgot your uncle manny's
address
[Laughter]
don't address this if you're going to be
at the post
i'll help office let's go he's [ __ ]
great
dude i love joe that's a great one of my
favorite uncle manny
love joe a lot of filipinos have the
name manny as well you know
yeah a lot of manny a lot of spanish
last names too hmm
i like that joe coy made it a merch
commercial and a commercial for his
netflix special he got so funny he got
them both in there
yeah he's a killer he's one of my
favorite people
you're first one yeah yeah yeah i would
love to meet that yeah i opened for jo
koi
you did wow the nicest guy
yeah oh yeah the nicest guy gives
everyone a joe what up man
you don't oh you don't know joe oh
you're just a fan
yeah he's [ __ ] great dude yeah
he's living in vegas yeah yeah he lives
in base he does
yeah wow sends me a video to him on atvs
and [ __ ]
that's fun and he was like oh is la shut
down still like
well yeah dude he's like i've just been
out here in the desert
this big ass lot wow shooting some music
video this week you want to talk about a
hustler
do you hear how he got on netflix you
ever hear the story how you got that on
netflix yeah
they they turned into that thing yeah
they kept turning they wouldn't do it
they weren't taken he's like this that
time when
netflix was just starting to pop he's
like well i got to be on there like all
the big communities are on there
now he's like we're good man so he shot
it high production shot it put all his
money into it
and was like netflix take it you can
have it for free oh that first one that
one he did in washington where he blew
up
and he blew up yeah and then he has a
show now on netflix too where he goes
the philippines yeah yeah
he has like a bunch of [ __ ] yeah on
netflix but they were like nope
nope then he filmed it all himself and
was like you just have for free if you
just put it on yeah
they didn't blew up okay you know what
that boy sells
like what 18 shows at brea 18 shows that
breath sold out the forum
i mean he sells out uh hawaii like a
[ __ ]
unreal but he sold out where the [ __ ]
warriors play that giant arena oh the
he does yeah or uh twice
he's arena play now damn wow monster
and the nicest guy in the world well
and i'm still doing this shitty show
here
wait did we even answer what the best
looking asian is we didn't even answer
brendan yeah yeah korean dude
let him talk dude he's going to die of
arteriosclerosis
from running a bunch of hamburger joints
any month now
um the hottest asians
are probably thai oh
that's a good one let's bring it bring
up some thai
that's a great call wow you surprised me
with that wow that's a great call
pull up a batch of thai nick oh jack
talk tai
i want to see uh some thai let's see
what we got here
also probably the best food out of the
asian cultures let's go to that one with
food there we go let's see what's up
here so good okay now here's dye right
here
and the beautiful thing about this is
you don't know if they're women or men
yep
wow the lady boys out there tricked you
ryan calling got tricked
didn't realize it he grabbed a whole
handful full of nuts
and then he didn't want to disrespect
the
whatever the the man so he just kept
going don't kiss him
really really you don't want to hurt his
feelings i respect that
right i mean i don't like i wouldn't do
it probably if i could you can see
yeah but i think a good guy very
respectful of different cultures
yeah he's a good guy well yeah because
he can't tell out there
yeah and look the the wild thing is is
they don't really have a lot of hips
so you don't really know that hips is in
a giveaway
that crot that whole hip hip booty area
it's all very
vague around there i think you want to
be suspicious of any of them that cover
up their wrists
that's a kind of a big tell you how do
you know this
sounds like you've had some experience
i've heard pray tell and like seeing
across the room and they'll have gloves
on or something
at a club have you been there huh
i was at a packer bar in santa monica
it's called uh
mom moz or something okay and uh there
was a girl sitting by herself she was
all decked out in packer gear
we were talking to her she was from
germany she loved the packers she was
drinking beer
we were like talking to each other and
we exchanged numbers and one of my
buddies when she left she was he was
like
that was a dude and then so i
i was already i was like honestly
actually you might be right now that i
think about it but i was just kind of
texting
kind of get more info and i was like
because we had made plans for saturday
yeah i was like so what are you going
what are you doing tomorrow and she's
like uh i thought i was going to hit up
the abbey
and i was like all right i'm out because
abby is uh
the gay bar a lot of straight women go
there too
yeah not by themselves when they're
overseas from germany i don't think
maybe you never know dude
either way i'm not a risk i'm willing to
take
come on nick i live a little dude
well here's the thing when i was really
a child if somebody else if you liked
women and somebody had a wiener
it was really more taboo you know sure
now it's not as wild because people
getting their wieners taken off
titty put on you know somebody put a
titty where their wiener was
you know they got people out there
pissing out of a d cup you know
this is a different ball game now but
i'm going to say what is the best
looking asian brennan you have to answer
and you can't just piggyback off of
these good people's answers
listen i think it's case by case you
know what's awesome is she japanese
it's case by case yes probably i i guess
japanese i'll go different japanese but
usually korean
what like the korean pop stars are
pretty smoky but then they do have
surgery so it's kind of a toss up you
know
what about a lot of work from charlie's
angels lucy lou
lucy lou chinese they're all they're all
they're all a bunch of pretty girls that
are asian
but you know a lot of beautiful women
yeah yeah even though i'm korean
i've only pretty much dated vietnamese i
think vietnamese girls are
same the cutest yeah oh yeah both of you
guys are dating vietnamese girls
then i'm gonna go to vietnam
you bet hey nick have you exclusive
you've only dated asian women
is that your type or this is just no
it's my first i was uh
this is the longest i've ever dated a
degree girl uh yeah
don't hurt him daddy uncle tom
bro black girls
they say yeah said uncle tom stabbins
there's a lot of girls
i think i'm blushing wow
the cheese head with a beard
that dark queso bro
that's cinnamon queso baby nick you
didn't have any clue that
you were talking to a man setting up a
date on saturday with a man
nothing set off red flags the german
accent i think
hid a lot of it and she was she was uh
asian no she's white
oh white oh dude your buddy might have
lied to you because i feel like that's
like yeah that's that would be easier to
know
i'm picturing an asian person in a
packers gear from germany
and that would be a little you're like i
don't know yeah there's a little bit of
common [ __ ] dude with a cheese hat on
and you thought it was a chick did you
mess with
you might have been
no i think it was a chick nick it sounds
like it was a chick it's a german chick
is almost a man
missed opportunity but now i met my
girlfriend so everything works out
his loss
[Music]
and i stand